nobody knows why the targaryens first
came to the island of dragonstone
old valyria was then at the height of
its power in the center of the civilized
world which ended at the narrow sea
westeros was a filthy backwater with
seven kings squabbling over borders and
minor glories
so much for progress
the island itself was and is nothing it
had no gold or gems to lure valyrian
nobility all it has is rock mostly a
shiny black stone too brittle for war
and too sharp for building the
targaryens called it dragonglass
i call it useless
but the targaryens managed to raise a
castle here simpletons claim they used
ancient valyrian sorcery forgetting that
the targaryens brought a small army with
them from essos there's no magic in
strong backs though admittedly the
castle is unlike any in westeros
foreign and
strange
if the targaryens ever regretted their
baron outpost and longed for the
comforts of home the doom made their
folly permanent
valyria collapsed into the waves and was
no more
to look east was to see the ruin of
their homeland the greatest civilization
before or since
but to look west
as aegon realized was to see a fertile
land ripe for conquest
perhaps even a new valyria
though good for little else dragonstone
was the perfect staging point for
aegon's invasion of westeros the
blackwater bay granted easy access to
the continent the lands there were
disputed by three kingdoms the reach the
iron islands and the stormlands but
their capitals were far enough away that
none could mount a force before aegon
got a foothold
even if their kings had been able to
stop bickering over whose problem he was
then it was too late
aegon had chosen his first camp well
with the bay to the east the river to
the south and open fields to the north
and west his army would be impossible to
take by surprise a perfect site for an
invasion and one day
his capital city
king's landing
aegon targaryen landed to our south
and as had many before him
liked the look of the riverlands
my ancestor edmund tully led the
desertion of riverlords to his cause and
was rewarded by getting to watch king
harren burn in his own tower
on the shores of the god's eye due north
of the isle of faces
rises a monument to arrogance and
cruelty
heron hull
for a people who prided themselves on
their ships
the iron men of old seized any chance to
leave them
and carved out a vast kingdom from the
peaceful river lords
the empire reached its zenith under king
heron horror
called the black by those he terrorized
and by his own men
though they meant it proudly
king heron enslaved the riverlands to
raise the mightiest fortress westeros
had ever seen
a castle that could garrison a million
men with walls so vast that winters
would come and go and besieging armies
grow old and gray before the castle fell
five towers he ordered
reaching into the heavens like grasping
fingers
a monstrosity
which he forced our people to build for
their own subjugation
but the very day the slaves laid the
last stone
aegon targaryen and his sisters arrived
in the south
when they arrived with their small army
heron laughed and shut the gates
harrenhal would have its first test and
an easy one at that
it failed
herron hall could have withstood an
assault from all the armies in westeros
combined
but heron learned that the tallest and
thickest walls meant little to dragons
for dragons fly
the problem with huge castles as they
blind you to what's outside both by
their size and the arrogance they
inspire
not that the ironborn ever lacked for
that
they take pride in their ignorance of
every trapping of civilization
though any baker could have told them
that fire turned stone walls into an
oven
and so harren the black finally lived up
to his name and the river lord swept the
ironborn back to the sea
when aegon the conqueror came to the
iron islands the priest king lodos
claimed his divine father the ironborn's
drowned god had shown him kraken's
pulling aegon's ships into the deep
no kraken's ever arrived and even if
they had they wouldn't have stopped
hagen and his dragons without wings of
their own
confused lodus filled his pockets with
stones and walked into the sea to
take counsel with his
father thousands followed him but
apparently the drowned god didn't
appreciate a crowd
their corpses washed upon the iron
islands for years
when aegon targaryen declared that
westeros was now his
king mern the ninth allied with king
loren lannister of the westerlands
together they fought to save westeros
from another foreign barbarian
whose family practices were a decent
mental shame
but the dragons won
and the field of fire claimed mern and
all his sons grandsons and brothers
instead of using the castle for what it
was built to do
harlan tyrell
surrendered it to aegon without a fight
in exchange
harlan was given the castle his family
had served for thousands of years with
all its attendant lands and lords
for over a thousand years the green
hands sons and grandsons ruled the reach
as house gardener the offshoots of his
daughters grew into vast and powerful
houses in their own right except for
house tyrell
we chose instead to serve our gardener
cousins faithfully as stewards
to manage their stronghold of highgarden
and the daily affairs of the reach
our words are growing strong
and under our stewardship the reach did
just that as did we
until a blundering king almost cost us
everything
aegon targaryen had landed in westeros
king mirn allied us with the roth to
repel the upstarts
army one can only marvel that king mirn
did not reconsider
when he saw the living dragons against
him
perhaps he should have sought counsel
from his trusted stewards before he set
out
then again perhaps he did
at the field of fire aegon
and let us not forget his sisters
burnt the combined armies of the reach
and rock king mirn paid for his
misjudgment with his life and that of
his ancient family
in a day the reach had lost its king its
ruling house and most of its army
thankfully for everyone
my ancestor harlan tyrell had better
sense
until the maesters sorted out the intel
among mern's cousins
harlan the steward was acting lord of
highgarden
to ensure peace and life in the reach he
would yield the castle to aegon
the other castles and families would
then follow
as they had since the dawn age
aegon had a continent to conquer
and the fertile reach was too valuable
to raise
he accepted harlan's proposal and
welcomed our lands into his kingdom
to show his gratitude
aegon entitled harlan to highgarden
the castle his family had served for a
thousand years
and made house tyrell his wardens of the
south choosing us over older greater
families in the reach
our house thus owed everything to the
targaryens
the lannisters reigned as kings of the
rock for thousands of years and worked
to make it the envy of the rest of the
seven kingdoms
our time as kings ended however when
aegon targaryen otherwise known as aegon
the conqueror arrived in westeros with
his army
the last king of the rock king lauren
lannister joined forces with king mern
gardner the king of the reach
together with sixty thousand men they
met the targaryen host in open battle
history tells us that aegon unleashed
all three of his dragons slaughtering
four thousand men at what came to be
known as the field of fire
king man himself was burned alive that
day and house gardener turned to ash
with him
seeing both the threat and opportunity
the targaryens represented
lauren wisely surrendered and aided
aegon in his further conquest of
westeros
the lannisters were thus appointed lords
paramount of the westerlands and wardens
of the west
titles we hold to this day
while aegon burned the kings of the iron
islands the rock and the reach his
fiercest commander and rumored brother
or his baratheon set out to subdue the
stormlands no matter how fierce a
warrior he was
no one could have ended his task
storm's end had seen thousands of years
of war and never fallen
but argilac the storm king chose not to
barricade himself behind its walls and
gave always the battle he must have
hoped for
oris slewed argilac and took argilac's
castle kingdom daughter sigil and house
words
house baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands
when aegon and his dragons landed on
westeros
the kings of the rock and the reach sent
all their men to die to defend their
grounds
tauren stark knelt to spare his people
the same fate
he placed duty above pride
the south had already fallen to aegon
and his dragons only the north remained
my ancestor king torrenstak marched the
north down to the trident and beheld
aegon's army larger than torrens owned
by half and with three dragons circling
overhead
many northern bannermen wanted to attack
anyway claiming northern valor would
carry the day
others wanted to fall back to moat
kaelin and make a stand there
but tauren had heard how the armies of
the rock and the reach had burned on the
field of fire and had seen the fires
still glowing beneath the rubble of
harrenhal
he knelt and laid his ancient crown at
aegon's feet and rose a king no more but
lord of winterfell and warden of the
north
some northerners still sneer at my
ancestor as the king who knelt
forgetting that because of tauren
they're alive today to sneer their
ancestors didn't leave their burned
bones at the trident and their twisted
swords didn't fill aegon's new throne
no army in the seven kingdoms can match
the pride and chivalry of the knights of
the vale
after all they were the first true
knights in westeros
until the dragons changed the game
when aegon the conqueror landed in
westeros the queen regent of the vale
shut the bloody gate against the
targaryens and masked the knights of the
vale behind it to lock it but forsenya
simply flew her dragon to a balcony of
the erie where the boy king was playing
and gave the boy a ride round the castle
in return for his mother's submission
when aegon the conqueror landed in
westeros
the high septon locked himself in a sept
for seven days and seven nights
finally the crone lifted her golden lamp
and showed him the path ahead the high
septon himself would anoint and crown
aegon as lord of the seven kingdoms
and the faith militant rallied behind
aegon
in governing his newly united land
yet aegon and his sisters never wholly
accepted the faith the high septon had
conceded aegon's marriages to his
sisters as a relic of his valerian
heritage which would soon fade
aegon targaryen sought to unite westeros
as nymeria had dorne
the other six kingdoms fell quickly
before his dragons and ambition
when his sister wife rhaenys flew her
dragon south and demanded our surrender
as well princess maria martell warned
i will not fight you
nor will i kneel to you
dorne has no king
tell your brother that
rhaenys threatened that the next time
the targaryens would come with fire and
blood
maria replied
you may burn us my lady but you will not
bend us
break us
or make us bow
this is dorne
you are not wanted here return at your
peril
rhaenys did
and she died
her dragon died
all her soldiers died
eventually her brother the conqueror
conceded that what nymeria had done
he could not undo
generations later another foolish
targaryen invaded dorne
he died as well
eventually we did join the seven
kingdoms but when we wanted and on our
terms
you